في اليوم الاول الهدنه الخامسه تجددت
الاشتباكات في الخرطوم في خرق للهدنه التي
تم التوصل اليها بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع وافاد مراسل الجزيره ان
السلاح الجو السوداني عاود قصف اهداف في
الخرطوم بحري والمضادات التابعه للدعم
السريع حاولت التصدي للغارات كما افاد
مراسل الجزيره بوقوع تبادل لاطلاق النار
في محيط القصر الجمهوري بالتزامن معدوي في
جارات واضاف ان اعمده الدخان تتصاعد في
شرقي الخرطوم بحري مشيرا الى ان مضادات
الدعم السريع اطلقت نيرانها على مقاله
انها طائرات الجيش في ضاحيه كافوري كما
افاد بان قذائف سقطت في جزيره توتي وسط
الخرطوم
واظهرت صور تصاعد اعمده دخان كثيف في
جزيره توتي وسط العاصمه السودانيه بعد
سقوط عده قذائف عليها